a local mayor changing political parties
after claiming there is a socialist
takeover of the democratic party north
las vegas mayor john lee made that big
announcement on national television this
morning
and now hopes nevada and nevadans will
also make the switch as well
christian cazarez caught up with the
mayor today and he said the decision was
really long overdue
that's right brian well mayor john lee
tells me the democratic party is a
different kind of party than what he
remembers he said
it's time for new leadership a new
vision which he hopes to be a part of
now lee made the announcement on
national television today where he
called out the state democratic party as
being broken
and said it had it has been taken over
by card carrying socialists
who must be defeated many of the newly
elected state party officials
are affiliated with the democratic
socialists of america or dsa
the new message is also reflective on
his website where he's asking the
nevada to make the switch to people over
establishment
and rights over rhetoric as a republican
he wants to work
for the principles our nation was
founded on like smaller government
lower taxes and free speech among others
an effort that could keep him
going after his term ends next year
my plans right now i have some big
things happening in north las vegas
right now
and to complete that
project right now that i'm working on
and fixing and making
north las vegas the strongest state
pardon me the strongest city in the
state
is my concern right now yes i've been
talked to
and it's been explained to me how
important it would be but
i do have to finish my job in north las
vegas at least get far enough down the
line before i make a decision
lee would not confirm if he is planning
to run for another office like
governor he added the republican party
under trump's leadership has created a
party for the working class
he said he voted for trump twice which
gave him an eight-plus rating with the
national rifle association
now we did reach out to the nevada
democratic party for comment about this
announcement
but they did not respond lots of
questions obviously spawning from this
change
but again he said it's time for new
leadership a new vision and he wants to
be part of that
christian casa does 8 news now going to
be interesting to see what he does next
all right christian thanks